-Il dit qu'il n'est pas là
parce qu'il est avec France Gall.
...
-De toutes les chansons,
celles que tu retiens,
..ne sont rien qu'un mot cruel
sans lendemain.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
je n'aime rien.
Rien de ce qui me rappelle
tous ces refrains.
N'écoute pas les idoles.
Ecoute-moi.
Car moi seule,
je suis folle.
Folle de toi.
Ces chansons que tu fredonnes,
comment veux-tu..
..que je les aime ?
Personne ne l'a jamais pu..
..me faire croire que l'on se donne
à coeur perdu..
..pour se quitter à l'automne,
bien entendu.
N'écoute pas les idoles.
Ecoute-moi.
Car moi seule,
je suis folle.
Folle de toi.
J'ai peur et je te résiste,
tu sais pourquoi.
Je sais bien ce que je risque
seule avec toi.
Pourtant, j'irai chez toi
puisque c'est comme ça.
Rien que pour casser tes disques,
tu ne pourras..
..plus écouter les idoles.
Ca t'apprendra...
Que moi seule,
je suis folle.
Folle de toi.
-C'est une enfant,
il faut être raisonnable.